pratik presidential candidate Jill Biden
emphatically denied allegations that he
sexually assaulted a former Senate
staffer in the early 90s Tara Reid said
she filed a complaint against Biden but
he says he doesn't believe one exists
now Biden is asking for Secretary of the
Senate to release his records at O'Keefe
reports in his first public remarks
since the allegations surfaced Joe Biden
on Friday explicitly denied the assault
I'm saying unequivocally it never never
happened
who didn't never happened Tara Reid who
was a 28 year old staffer and Biden
Senate office back in 1993 says he
assaulted her in a Capitol Hill hallway
Reid says she later complained to the
Senate personnel office but that her
complaint didn't mention sexual assault
on Friday Biden called for the release
of any record of Reid's complaint it was
there put it out but I've never seen it
Senate personnel records are managed by
the Secretary of the Senate who didn't
respond to requests for comment some
have questioned whether there's a
mention of read in Biden's personal
Senate papers housed at the University
of Delaware Biden insists there isn't
and said he doesn't want them released
yet because they're mostly political all
of that to be fodder in a campaign at
this time I don't know of anybody who's
done anything like that
last year Reid recounted what she
considered to be inappropriate touching
by Biden in March she made the more
serious allegation of assault Biden
didn't directly answer if he remembered
her do you remember her I don't remember
any type of complaint she may have made
it was 27 years ago the campaign later
said that Biden did not remember her
president Trump who's been accused by
more than a dozen women of sexual
misconduct said Friday he found Reid to
be credible but I would just say to Joe
Biden just go out and fight it it's it's
you know one of those things
late Friday an attorney named bill
Jeffers who had led the vetting of Biden
for Barack Obama before he chose Biden
to be his vice presidential running mate
back into
they told me that during their six to
eight week investigation of Biden's
background there were never any
allegations of sexual misconduct against
Biden when I asked whether the name Tara
Reid or her accusations ever came up in
their investigation
Jeffers said no that he'd only learned
about her last week
Jeff interesting all right okay thank
you very much